This episode of 100 Objects is brought to you by Anthropic, the team behind Claude. Claude is the AI for minds that don't stop at good enough. It's the collaborator that actually understands your entire workflow and thinks with you. Whether you're debugging code at midnight or strategizing your next business move, Claude extends your thinking to tackle the problems that matter. Build interactive tools and apps by describing what you need. Custom calculators, data visualization dashboards, even prototypes, all without writing a single line of code.
本期《100件物品》节目由Claude背后的团队Anthropic赞助。Claude是为那些不满足于“足够好”的头脑而设计的AI。它是一位真正理解你的整个工作流程并与你共同思考的合作伙伴。无论你是在午夜调试代码，还是在为下一个商业决策制定战略，Claude都能扩展你的思维，助你解决重要问题。通过描述你的需求，你可以构建交互式工具和应用程序。无论是自定义计算器、数据可视化仪表板，甚至是原型设计，无需编写一行代码即可完成。
For problems worth solving, get started with Claude at claw.a.i. That's clod.a.i. It's the 1970s, and we're in the peaceful bliss of suburbia, in a family home, pretty indistinguishable from any other family home. But for one curious child, it was in these four walls that there lived a precious, almost mythical object. It was in the front foyer of our house. There was a table devoted to it.
对于值得解决的问题，请访问claw.a.i开始使用Claude。即clod.a.i。那是20世纪70年代，我们生活在郊区宁静的幸福中，住在一个与任何其他家庭住宅没什么两样的房子里。但对于一个好奇的孩子来说，正是这四面墙内，住着一件珍贵的、近乎神话般的物品。它就在我们家的前厅里。有一张专门放它的桌子。
This is Adam Savage. I am a former Mythbuster, current YouTuber, science communicator, and maker of things. And breaker of things. And breaker of things. You have to break enough things to learn how they go back together. But one of the few things Adam was never quite able to break was what sat on that table in the front foyer of his home. Picture, you know, the classic picture of a telephone in the encyclopedia, this black phone with a metal dial, letters in each hole of the dial, and a handset sitting on top.
我是亚当·萨维奇（Adam Savage）。我曾是《流言终结者》的主持人，现在是一名YouTuber、科学传播者和创客。也是破坏者。也是破坏者。你必须破坏足够多的东西，才能学会它们是如何重新组装在一起的。但亚当从未能完全破坏的东西之一，就是他家前厅桌子上放的那件东西。想象一下，你知道百科全书里电话的经典图片，那部带有金属拨号盘、拨号盘每个孔里都有字母、上面放着听筒的黑色电话。
This phone was the Western Electric 500 series, and it was kind of just to end ordinary telephone. In fact, it was the ordinary telephone. So ordinary that at the time, you would have found some version of it in pretty much every home in America. So I'm an elder Gen X, born in the late 60s. We had one telephone in our house for my entire. childhood until I went to college. And Adam still remembers everything about it. Everything around the phone, from the tactility of dialing into zika, zika, zika,
这部电话是西部电气（Western Electric）500系列，它不仅仅是普通的电话。事实上，它就是“那部”普通电话。普通到在当时，你几乎可以在美国的每个家庭中找到它的某个版本。我是一个老派的X世代，出生于60年代末。在我上大学之前的整个童年时代，我们家里只有一部电话。亚当至今仍记得关于它的一切。电话周围的一切，从拨号时的触感，滋咔、滋咔、滋咔，
putting your finger in the metal dial, the coldness of the dial, the fact that it kind of rang slightly as you moved it around, it was all part of this ritual of conversation. Yeah. I remember really loving the dial tone, the sort of the comforting sound of the dial tone. You'll hear the dial tone.
把手指放进金属拨号盘，拨号盘的冰冷感，以及当你转动它时它发出的轻微响声，这些都是对话仪式的一部分。是的。我记得我真的很喜欢拨号音，那种拨号音带来的舒适感。你会听到拨号音。
You'll hear the dial tone. One of my earliest memories is sitting there with my friend John Massaro, and we took the phone handset off this phone, and we put a banana in its place on the phone, and then the phone rang, which we did not expect that that was possible. And the fact that the phone still operated with a banana on it was twice as funny as the funniest thing that they ever happened to us. But most of Adam's memories of the phone revolved around the object's
你会听到拨号音。我最早的记忆之一是和我的朋友约翰·马萨罗（John Massaro）坐在那里，我们把听筒从电话上拿下来，放了一个香蕉在电话上，然后电话响了，我们完全没想到这竟然是可能的。而且电话在放了香蕉的情况下还能正常工作，这比我们经历过的任何事情都要好笑两倍。但亚当关于电话的大部分记忆都围绕着这件物品的
true purpose to connect you with people who were far away. I remember having fights with my best friend in high school in that chair, talking to my girlfriend in that chair. Then I felt like I could hear the whole inside of her house, right? And it is a machine that gives me a presence in the other person's space. That's what it feels like. Like, I'm not just hearing a voice. I'm hearing the environment they're in, and I'm feeling like I'm part of it.
真正目的：让你与远方的人建立联系。我记得在那个椅子上和最好的朋友吵架，在那个椅子上和女朋友聊天。那时我觉得我能听到她家里的所有声音，对吧？它是一台让我在对方空间里产生存在感的机器。感觉就是这样。就像，我不只是在听一个声音。我听到了他们所处的环境，我觉得自己是其中的一部分。
And we would talk for like two and a half hours, three hours. It wasn't unheard of to be like three, four, like you just were, you hung on the phone. Yeah. And what I really remember was the feeling of immediacy of that conversation. And it didn't matter what we were talking about. It felt like we were together in the same room. It's a feeling we don't really feel anymore. The feeling of sitting on a phone line, hearing the whole inside of somebody's house,
我们会聊上两个半小时、三个小时。聊上三四个小时并不罕见，就像你只是，你挂在电话上。是的。我真正记得的是那种对话的即时感。无论我们聊什么都不重要。感觉就像我们在一起，在同一个房间里。这是一种我们现在已经不再有的感觉。那种坐在电话线旁，听着别人家里所有声音的感觉，
like you're actually there with them in person. I think the Bell Telephone, the 500 series, is arguably the best consumer product ever built. They make 92 million of this one phone over 50 years. And for 50 years, it is the best device ever for talking to other people at a distance, and we no longer have that. This one model of telephone became ubiquitous
就像你真的亲自和他们在一起一样。我认为贝尔电话公司（Bell Telephone）的500系列可以说是史上最伟大的消费产品。他们在50年内生产了9200万部这种电话。在50年里，它是远距离与他人交谈的最佳设备，而我们现在不再拥有它了。这一款电话型号变得无处不在，
across the continental United States for 50 years, and then it just disappeared completely. What does that say about what kind of human connection we prioritize and what we let fade away? From 99% Invisible and BBC Studios, this is a history of the United States and 100 objects. I'm Roman Mars. Today, the Western Electric 500 series, and how one device, which was once near omnipresent in every single household in America created a level of interpersonal connection and intimacy unlike any object ever had before. And why over time, we decided to give that up. The history of the telephone is really the story of how America became connected. So let's back up. Could you describe like before the phone shows up in our lives,
遍布美国大陆50年，然后它就完全消失了。这说明了我们优先考虑什么样的以及我们让什么样的人际联系逐渐消逝？来自《99%隐形》（99% Invisible）和BBC工作室，这是《美国历史与100件物品》。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。今天，我们要讲的是西部电气500系列，以及这一度在美国家庭中几乎无处不在的设备，是如何创造出一种前所未有的、独特的人际联系和亲密感的。以及为什么随着时间的推移，我们决定放弃它。电话的历史实际上是美国如何实现互联的故事。那么让我们回顾一下。你能描述一下在电话出现在我们生活中之前，
what are we dealing with? Well, for normal people getting a message a great distance, The main thing people could use was Western Union. There were telegraphs and teletypes. The telegraph was a fairly rudimentary system that involved wires and tapping out messages in Morse code. And very quickly, Western Union realizes this technology can carry messages across an ocean at unheard of speed. The telegraph, along with the trains, compresses the world so quickly
我们面对的是什么吗？嗯，对于普通人来说，要远距离传递信息，人们主要使用的是西联汇款（Western Union）。那时有电报和电传打字机。电报是一个相当原始的系统，涉及电线和用摩尔斯电码敲击信息。很快，西联汇款意识到这项技术可以以惊人的速度跨洋传递信息。电报，连同火车，如此迅速地压缩了世界，
that it's one of the reasons we ended up with the international time. because people were talking across great distances and it got everyone really cranky. But despite being able to send messages across the ocean, telegraphy had a pretty central flaw. You were very limited in terms of the language you could use. It was very expensive. Every word cost you money.
以至于它是我们最终采用国际时间的原因之一。因为人们在远距离交谈，这让每个人都非常暴躁。但尽管能够跨洋发送信息，电报有一个相当核心的缺陷。你在语言使用方面非常受限。它非常昂贵。每一个字都要花钱。
So this is where you see those old movies where they're like, It's from London. Oh. Mr. Gower cables, you need cash. Stop. My office instructed to advance you up to $25,000. Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, stop because that was smaller word than period for communicating. Really?
所以这就是为什么你会看到那些老电影，他们说：来自伦敦。哦。高尔先生（Mr. Gower）发来电报，你需要现金。停止。我的办公室指示预付你25000美元。等等等等，停止。因为那是比句号更短的词，用于交流。真的吗？
Yeah. Yeah, stop is the shortest word that means period. Huh, I had no idea. This brevity was necessitated by the fact that early telegraphy cables could only carry a single message at once, and time was money. Couple that with the fact that a professional operator would need to be reading your whole message at the other end, whether it was private or not, meant that telegraphs weren't exactly conversational. You had technology helping them communicate across greater distances, but there was nothing
是的。是的，停止（stop）是表示句号的最短词。哈，我完全不知道。这种简洁性是由于早期的电报电缆一次只能携带一条信息，而且时间就是金钱。再加上另一端的专业操作员需要阅读你的整条信息，无论它是否私密，这意味着电报并不完全是对话式的。你有技术帮助他们进行远距离交流，但没有任何东西
really personal about it. So this is also a time when people were writing, like people finish their days writing, you know, half a dozen letters to people. Yeah, yeah. In fact, the writing was really expansive. Like you get huge letters about people's days. You know what I mean? It's crazy when you read about these folks like reading what Washington's, letters. Like every day he finishes spending two hours just hand calligraphing, often two copies of everything. He's writing every letter twice, so he has a record. These guys were writing thousands of words a day sometimes. I get really tired thinking about how much they were hand writing. But writing the letter was a painfully slow form of communication compared to the telegraph.
是真正私人的。所以这也是人们写信的时代，比如人们结束一天的工作后写信，你知道，给人们写半打信。是的，是的。事实上，写作是非常广泛的。就像你收到关于人们日常生活的长信。你知道我的意思吗？当你读到像华盛顿的信件时，这很疯狂。他每天结束工作后都要花两个小时手写书法，通常每样东西都有两份副本。他把每封信都写两遍，这样他就有记录了。这些人有时每天写几千个字。想到他们手写了多少东西，我就觉得很累。但与电报相比，写信是一种极其缓慢的交流方式。
It would take weeks to reach somebody. And so people were trying to find a way to marry the conversational personal qualities of letters with the spontaneity and ease of the telegraph. Western Union offered $1 million to anybody who could develop a multiplex system, which would allow for multiple telegraph transmissions simultaneously. But around this time, something else emerges. Something that will threaten the domination of the telegraph. You know, the creation of telephone is highly disputed. There's many claims and counterclaims about its invention.
它需要几周时间才能传达到某人手中。因此，人们试图找到一种方法，将信件的对话式个人品质与电报的自发性和便捷性结合起来。西联汇款向任何能开发出多路复用系统的人提供100万美元，该系统将允许同时进行多次电报传输。但就在这个时候，其他东西出现了。一些将威胁到电报统治地位的东西。你知道，电话的创造是有很大争议的。关于它的发明有很多主张和反主张。
You don't say. So what is the simplest story to explain the invention on the telephone? The story we were all taught in schools that Alexander Graham Bell was working on the attempt to make a mechanical way for transmitting sound, figuring out a way to transmit sound through wires. Despite many claims and counterclaims, Bell's invention would secure the patent, meaning he was the only one who could legally make a telephone.
你没开玩笑吧。那么，解释电话发明的最简单的故事是什么？我们在学校里学到的故事是，亚历山大·格拉汉姆·贝尔（Alexander Graham Bell）正在尝试制造一种传输声音的机械方式，想出一种通过电线传输声音的方法。尽管有许多主张和反主张，贝尔的发明获得了专利，这意味着他是唯一一个可以合法制造电话的人。
And everybody wanted one. Well, everybody but Bell himself. who famously refused to have a telephone in his own study for fear of distraction. It was a smart man. And Bell's design was both a stroke of genius and actually fairly simple. The basic mechanism I believe Bell was working with was a magnetic coil with a membrane. And using your voice to vibrate that membrane to create an electrical signal, then that gets converted into mechanical movement at the other end of the equation and converted back into sound.
每个人都想要一个。好吧，除了贝尔本人。他以害怕分心为由，拒绝在自己的书房里安装电话。他是个聪明人。贝尔的设计既是天才之作，实际上也相当简单。我相信贝尔使用的基本机制是一个带有膜片的磁线圈。利用你的声音振动那个膜片来产生电信号，然后这在等式的另一端被转换为机械运动，并转换回声音。
Yeah, yeah. So this is an analog process where the vibrations of my voice are moving a small membrane, and those movements transmit small amounts of difference of an electrical signal that can then be just picked up as an analog signal on the other side and converted back into the same mechanical movement so you hear sound. The miracle of this invention, what is absolutely amazing about it, is that the time it takes for this analog system to work is nearly instantaneous, milliseconds, almost impossible to detect for the human ear.
是的，是的。所以这是一个模拟过程，我声音的振动移动了一个小膜片，这些运动传输了微小的电信号差异，然后可以在另一端作为模拟信号被接收，并转换回相同的机械运动，这样你就能听到声音。这项发明的奇迹，绝对令人惊叹的是，这个模拟系统工作所需的时间几乎是瞬时的，几毫秒，对于人耳来说几乎无法察觉。
Now, a single telephone is a triumph of engineering, but for the invention to truly matter, you need to get as many phones out in the world as possible and connect them all via copper wires. You need to build a network. So he creates Bell Telephone. It matriculates into AT&T American Telephone and Telegraph in the early 20th century. While they're not exactly the same thing,
现在，一部电话是工程学的胜利，但要让这项发明真正发挥作用，你需要让世界上尽可能多的人拥有电话，并通过铜线将它们连接起来。你需要建立一个网络。于是他创建了贝尔电话公司。它在20世纪初演变成了AT&T（美国电话电报公司）。虽然它们不完全是一回事，
people generally use Bell Telephone interchangeably with AT&T. Bell Laboratories, Western Electric, long lines. It's the local telephone company. And finally, AT&T, the parent company. Five parts, but known collectively as the Bell system. In reality, they are all facets of one massive telecommunications company. And it is the most rapaciously capitalist enterprise you could imagine. At this moment in the early 1900s, Bell has the patent for the telephone, but it doesn't have the patent for the miles of copper cables that are required to make that phone work.
人们通常把贝尔电话公司和AT&T互换使用。贝尔实验室、西部电气、长途线路。它是当地的电话公司。最后是AT&T，母公司。五个部分，但统称为贝尔系统。实际上，它们都是一家庞大的电信公司的各个方面。而且它是你能想象到的最贪婪的资本主义企业。在20世纪初的这一刻，贝尔拥有电话的专利，但它没有制造该电话所需的数英里铜缆的专利。
And other companies realize this. They figure out they can lay down local wires and get in on the telephone boom. Bell doesn't like this. While there's nothing they can do to stop local providers connecting people, Bell does have a couple tricks up its sleeve. They refuse to let these local lines interface with their national network. And they are buying up every possible competitor as they arrive because they have the monopoly. And they use the money they make from their monopoly to just keep on eating more small companies that show up in the space. It's a classic perfect model of what a monopoly does with its monopoly power.
其他公司意识到了这一点。他们发现他们可以铺设当地线路并参与电话热潮。贝尔不喜欢这样。虽然他们无法阻止当地供应商连接人们，但贝尔确实有几个锦囊妙计。他们拒绝让这些当地线路与他们的全国网络连接。而且他们正在买下每一个出现的竞争对手，因为他们拥有垄断地位。他们利用从垄断中赚来的钱，继续吞并更多出现在这个领域的小公司。这是垄断企业利用其垄断力量所作所为的经典完美模型。
But a classic model of monopoly was also a classic target for the government to break up. The government had just broken up standard oil and the American tobacco company. And now it was starting to why AT&T. But the president of AT&T, a man named Theodore Veil, came to the government with an offer. I feel like he must have had an epiphany because around about 1913, 14, he starts reaching out to the U.S. government
但垄断的经典模型也是政府拆分的目标。政府刚刚拆分了标准石油公司和美国烟草公司。现在它开始关注AT&T。但AT&T的总裁，一个叫西奥多·维尔（Theodore Vail）的人，带着一个提议来到政府面前。我觉得他一定是有过顿悟，因为大约在1913、14年左右，他开始接触美国政府，
and offering a non-adversarial relationship. He starts saying, look, I know you guys think that we're a monopoly, but please don't break us up. Please don't subject us to antitrust laws. This was the deal. They would build a telephone system, so incredibly large that it would provide every single possible American business and home with a telephone signal. And they would supply this infrastructure for universal coverage completely free of charge.
并提供一种非对抗性的关系。他开始说，看，我知道你们认为我们是垄断企业，但请不要拆分我们。请不要让我们受反垄断法的约束。这就是交易。他们将建立一个电话系统，规模大到足以让每一个可能的美国企业和家庭都能获得电话信号。而且他们将完全免费提供这种基础设施，实现普遍覆盖。
But in return, they wanted a monopoly over the network. No more having to buy competitors out. No more fighting for permits to lay cables in any given neighborhood. The reason Vail, I think, gets the U.S. government to agree is he makes the case. that what AT&T needs to do is so large and so complex, it will happen faster and ultimately be better for the American public if one company is able to maintain a consistent standard across that whole network, rather than different companies having different standards of quality.
但作为回报，他们想要对网络的垄断权。不再需要收购竞争对手。不再需要为在任何特定社区铺设电缆而争取许可。我认为维尔之所以能让美国政府同意，是因为他提出了一个理由：AT&T需要做的事情规模如此之大，如此复杂，如果一家公司能够在该整个网络中保持统一的标准，而不是不同公司有不同的质量标准，那么它会发展得更快，最终对美国公众更好。
And the U.S. government agrees. It was a massive win for AT&T, but now the difficult part started. They needed to make sure every home or business in the country was connected by wire to every other home or business in the country. This becomes the thing that once you start to unpack, it makes what Bell Telephone and AT&T did so insanely incredible. It is such a massive engineering project getting actual copper wire to every last person in the United States. That isn't an exaggeration. AT&T wanted to connect the whole country, and they'd have to lay tens of millions of miles of copper cable to do it. You may have noticed that lots of work has been going on.
美国政府同意了。这对AT&T来说是一个巨大的胜利，但现在困难的部分开始了。他们需要确保全国的每一个家庭或企业都通过电线连接到全国的每一个其他家庭或企业。这成为了当你开始拆解时，让贝尔电话公司和AT&T所做的事情变得如此不可思议的事情。将实际的铜线送到美国每一个人的手中，这是一个如此庞大的工程项目。这并不夸张。AT&T想要连接整个国家，他们必须铺设数千万英里的铜缆才能做到。你可能已经注意到，很多工作一直在进行，
You cable pulled into place and other types of construction. And making the telephone system was not cheap. Usually the most expensive part was connecting the last mile, the part where the wires branched off from the main cables and wound their way into individual homes. Starting in 1925, AT&T starts Bell Labs. Bell Telephone Laboratories, the largest single organization in the world devoted exclusively to communications research. And the origin of Bell Labs is literally just to keep on making the network better and helping to design out how to get a phone to every last mile. And before long, Bell Labs came to a key realization.
电缆被拉到位以及其他类型的施工。制造电话系统并不便宜。通常最昂贵的部分是连接“最后一英里”，即电线从主电缆分支出来并蜿蜒进入各个家庭的部分。从1925年开始，AT&T成立了贝尔实验室。贝尔电话实验室，世界上唯一致力于通信研究的最大组织。贝尔实验室的起源实际上就是为了不断完善网络，并帮助设计如何将电话送到最后一英里。不久之后，贝尔实验室得出了一个关键的认识。
If they were going to painstakingly connect America with millions of miles of copper wire, they ought to create the perfect interface with which to use those wires. Bell Labs needed to create the perfect telephone. The man who would ultimately step up to the plate was Henry Dreyfus, who started his career as a prolific designer of Broadway sets, before branching out. He designs a movie theater where he puts an audience, in a giant round room with four screens at the four corners of the room and one soundtrack.
如果他们要费尽心思用数百万英里的铜线连接美国，他们就应该创造出使用这些电线的完美接口。贝尔实验室需要创造出完美的电话。最终挺身而出的人是亨利·德雷福斯（Henry Dreyfus），他职业生涯的起点是百老汇布景的多产设计师，之后才开始涉足其他领域。他设计了一家电影院，把观众放在一个巨大的圆形房间里，房间的四个角落有四个屏幕，还有一个音轨。
They're all watching the same movie, but they're able to fit way many more people in the room with no balconies and no like obstructions that increases both the audience satisfaction and the amount of money the theater owner can make. And I love this because Henry Dreyfus really early on is considering both the rules of commerce, i.e., we've got to make some money and also the experience of the people spending the money. money that's going to be made. In 1929, at the age of 25, Dreyfus started his own design shop, and his design philosophy was clear from the beginning.
他们都在看同一部电影，但他们能够容纳更多的人在房间里，没有阳台，也没有任何障碍物，这既提高了观众的满意度，也增加了剧院老板可以赚到的钱。我喜欢这一点，因为亨利·德雷福斯很早就考虑了商业规则，即我们必须赚点钱，同时也考虑了花钱的人的体验。将要赚到的钱。1929年，25岁的德雷福斯创办了自己的设计工作室，他的设计理念从一开始就很明确。
Dreyfus was saying there can be no friction between the use of a tool and its utility. Right? He wants to reduce the friction of using anything that he has building to the lowest possible common denominator. His shop designs the Honeywell thermostat. Like the default thermostat for the entire United States for decades. And this is the simplest tool there is. You turn the dial to the temperature you can see.
德雷福斯说，工具的使用与其效用之间不能有摩擦。对吧？他想把使用他所建造的任何东西的摩擦力降低到最低的公分母。他的工作室设计了霍尼韦尔（Honeywell）恒温器。就像几十年来整个美国的默认恒温器一样。这是最简单的工具。你转动拨盘到你能看到的温度。
There is nothing to know. But unlike the thermostat, there wasn't one perfect telephone that nearly all America used. The history of the design of the telephone is sort of a constant evolution. The first phone was the earpiece was separate than the headset. You had this old-timey little tube you held up to your ear while you spoke into this like tulip. And then there was a handset that put the microphone and the speaker in the same piece. But when AT&T wanted to make another evolution, they didn't go directly to Dreyfus to solve the problem. So AT&T has a contest to design the 300 series phone.
没有什么需要了解的。但与恒温器不同，并没有一个几乎全美国都在使用的完美电话。电话的设计历史是一种不断的演变。第一部电话的听筒与耳机是分开的。你有一个老式的管子，你说话时把它举到耳朵边，对着这个像郁金香一样的东西。然后有一个听筒，把麦克风和扬声器放在同一个部件里。但当AT&T想要进行另一次演变时，他们并没有直接去找德雷福斯来解决这个问题。所以AT&T举办了一场设计300系列电话的竞赛。
And they put a call out an RFP to Design Studios. Henry Dreyfus refuses to compete. he's like, I would like to talk to the designers and they're like, that's not part of the competition. He's like, then never mind. But after that contest yields no designs they like, they just hire Henry's firm to design the 300 phone. He just weights them out.
他们向设计工作室发出了RFP（需求建议书）。亨利·德雷福斯拒绝参加。他说，我想和设计师谈谈，他们说，那不是比赛的一部分。他说，那就算了。但在那场竞赛没有产生他们喜欢的设计后，他们直接聘请了亨利的公司来设计300型电话。他只是等待他们。
Oh, that's amazing. For people who don't know, like the world of spec work and design is like a extremely fraught world where you have to endure all these sort of design contests and do this work for free. And the fact that he had the confidence in his own self and his own research to just wait it out, is amazing. The weighting it out just blows my mind to smithereens. In 1937, Bell introduced the 300
哦，那太棒了。对于不知道的人来说，规格工作和设计的世界是一个极其令人焦虑的世界，你必须忍受所有这些设计竞赛，并免费做这些工作。而他对自己和自己的研究有信心，只是等待时机，这太棒了。这种等待让我感到无比震撼。1937年，贝尔推出了300
series model designed by Dreyfus. He used thousands of measurements from the quote, average American to determine the size and shape of the handset. And the result was pretty successful. They built millions of the series 300 phones, and they learned a tremendous amount from them. They learned they needed to put the ringer inside the body because I didn't know this, but you could buy early phones where the ringer was extra? I don't even know how you would get a call. Just wait till you hear someone yelling on your and you pick it up.
系列型号，由德雷福斯设计。他使用了来自所谓的“普通美国人”的数千个测量数据来确定听筒的大小和形状。结果非常成功。他们制造了数百万部300系列电话，并从中获益良多。他们了解到他们需要把铃声放在机身内部，因为我不知道这一点，但你可以买到早期的电话，铃声是额外的？我甚至不知道你怎么能接到电话。等着听有人在你旁边大喊大叫，然后你接起来。
So before long, Dryfus and his shop refined the design and he came out with an updated version, the 500 series. It must have been a 400 in between there, but you can just forget about that. Dreyfus's team improved the microphone, made the phone prettier, but maybe most importantly, in terms of its reliability, is they made it possible for the 500 series users
所以不久之后，德雷福斯和他的工作室改进了设计，并推出了更新版本，500系列。中间肯定有一个400系列，但你可以忽略它。德雷福斯的团队改进了麦克风，让电话更漂亮，但也许最重要的是，就其可靠性而言，他们使500系列用户有可能
to fix their device at home. It was also built for repairability. Nothing was attached to the body of the phone. Two screws pulled it off the chassis. Now you had access to all the electronics of the phone and it would still work and be testable so you could troubleshoot it much faster. This was the object designed to allow them
在家修理他们的设备。它也是为可维修性而制造的。没有任何东西连接在电话机身上。两颗螺丝就能把它从底盘上拆下来。现在你可以接触到电话的所有电子元件，它仍然可以工作并可测试，所以你可以更快地进行故障排除。这是一个旨在允许他们
to repair these things, to keep them operating. And these, the parts of the 500 series phone were compatible from 1949 to 1984. Oh my God. Western Electric, the hardware manufacturing division of AT&T, made over 90,000 500 series phones in just over 30 years. And the internal parts were almost entirely interchangeable. That meant if you bought a phone in 1950 and you broke it in 1960, the newest parts would still fit your old phone. And then if you broke it again 15 years later, the pieces on the market would still slot right in. And all of this, the interchangeability of parts, the ease of repairability, the intuitive troubleshooting were all conscious decisions made for a specific reason.
修理这些东西，保持它们运行的物体。而且这些，500系列电话的零件从1949年到1984年都是兼容的。天哪。西部电气，AT&T的硬件制造部门，在短短30多年里制造了超过9000万部500系列电话。内部零件几乎完全可以互换。这意味着如果你在1950年买了一部电话，而在1960年弄坏了它，最新的零件仍然适合你的旧电话。然后如果你15年后又弄坏了它，市场上的零件仍然可以直接装进去。所有这些，零件的互换性、维修的简易性、直观的故障排除，都是出于特定原因而做出的有意识的决定。
Actually, maybe people don't realize this, but people didn't own those phones. Those phones were all 92 million of those phones were the property of AT&T and they were rented to the customers. This is probably the most important fact, actually. regular Americans, Adams family, my family, your family, did not own their telephones. We rented them from AT&T. And in this fact, it really changes the things that you build because they're rented. Like, they do not want to make these things disposable. Western Electric builds rugged phones and test some of them beyond endurance.
其实，也许人们没有意识到这一点，但人们并不拥有那些电话。那些电话，那9200万部电话都是AT&T的财产，它们是租给客户的。这可能是最重要的事实，实际上。普通美国人，亚当的家庭，我的家庭，你的家庭，并不拥有他们的电话。我们是从AT&T租来的。而在这个事实中，它确实改变了你制造东西的方式，因为它们是租来的。就像，他们不想让这些东西成为一次性的。西部电气制造坚固的电话，并测试其中一些，使其超越耐用极限。
Chances are the phone your bell telephone company installs will never need repair. They want them to last decades because they do not want to replace them. Yes, that's the thing. The end user was not the customer. That's kind of amazing to me, right? It is so beefy. You can take your bell phone for granted because we don't. At Western Electric, manufacturing and supply unit of the bell system.
很有可能你的贝尔电话公司安装的电话永远不需要修理。他们希望它们能持续几十年，因为他们不想更换它们。是的，就是这样。最终用户不是客户。这对我来说有点令人惊讶，对吧？它太结实了。你可以认为你的贝尔电话是理所当然的，因为我们不这样做。在西部电气，贝尔系统的制造和供应单位。
It is so sturdy that when it shows up in pop culture, it is clear that this thing is nearly indestructible. In the movie Get Shorty. Gene Hackman is a Hollywood producer who tries to front to a genuine mafioso played by Dennis Frina who proceeds to beat the ever-living crap out of him with the handset and body of a 500 series telephone. Look at me, Ray.
它非常坚固，以至于当它出现在流行文化中时，很明显这个东西几乎是坚不可摧的。在电影《矮子当道》（Get Shorty）中。吉恩·哈克曼（Gene Hackman）是一位好莱坞制片人，他试图在丹尼斯·法里纳（Dennis Farina）饰演的真正的黑手党面前装腔作势，后者接着用500系列电话的听筒和机身把他打得半死。看着我，雷。
I'll tell you what, Harry. Why don't you take a look at this? And every blow hurts because I know how strong that thing is. You cannot break the handset. I have tried. A lot of people have. In Mr. and Mrs. Smith, Angelina Jolie's character gives it a go.
我告诉你，哈里。你为什么不看看这个？每一次打击都很痛，因为我知道那个东西有多结实。你无法弄坏那个听筒。我试过了。很多人都试过。在《史密斯夫妇》（Mr. and Mrs. Smith）中，安吉丽娜·朱莉（Angelina Jolie）的角色试了一下。
In American Hustle, Bradley Cooper's character gives it three goes. And in Once Upon a Time in Hollywood, I mean, it's pretty grim. If you see it, you know what I'm talking about. The 500 series is both incredibly sturdy, and it shows up everywhere. Hello, Neil and Buzz. I'm talking to you by telephone from the oval room at the White House. In what might be the greatest moment of his presidency, Nixon used a touch-tone version of the 500 series to call the Apollo 11 astronauts as they walked on the moon. I shall resign the presidency effective at noon tomorrow.
在《美国骗局》（American Hustle）中，布莱德利·库珀（Bradley Cooper）的角色试了三次。而在《好莱坞往事》（Once Upon a Time in Hollywood）中，我的意思是，这太残酷了。如果你看到了，你就知道我在说什么。500系列既极其坚固，又随处可见。你好，尼尔和巴兹。我正在白宫椭圆形办公室通过电话与你们交谈。在尼克松总统任期内最伟大的时刻，他使用了一个按键版的500系列电话，在阿波罗11号宇航员在月球上行走时给他们打电话。我将于明天中午辞去总统职务。
And when it all came crumbling down with those telephones being bugged at Watergate, well, those were almost certainly 500 series telephones too. Chances are, if a phone call was made in the United States between 1949 and 1984, it was most likely on a 500-series telephone. All this to say, the 500 series was a gigantic success. It was such a success that they also added different variants of the bell phone to appeal to different users. AT&T released the princess phone, a phone literally built for a teenage girl's hand. It's little, it's lovely, it likes the new princess phone. And the princess phone is the one, you know, every home in America in the 70s had a princess phone and a curly cord that was like 25 feet long
当水门事件中那些电话被窃听，一切都崩溃时，嗯，那些几乎肯定也是500系列电话。如果1949年到1984年间在美国打过电话，很有可能是在500系列电话上打的。所有这些都说明，500系列是一个巨大的成功。它非常成功，以至于他们还增加了贝尔电话的不同变体，以吸引不同的用户。AT&T发布了公主电话（Princess phone），一部字面上为十几岁女孩的手设计的电话。它很小，很可爱，它喜欢新的公主电话。而公主电话是那种，你知道，70年代美国每个家庭都有一个公主电话和一根大约25英尺长的卷曲电话线，
where you could get to kind of any given corner of your house for a private conversation. But everyone else was doing the limbo under this phone cord that was stretched across the house. A robust, rented bell telephone was a fixture of American life for over 30 years. It was omnipresent across culture and politics and the lives of everyday people.
你可以走到你家里的任何角落进行私人谈话。但其他人都在这根横跨房子的电话线下玩凌波舞。一部坚固的、租来的贝尔电话是美国生活30多年来的固定装置。它在文化、政治和普通人的生活中无处不在。
Eventually, it was replaced. In time, everything is. The real tragedy, is what we lost in the process. Let's take a break to talk about our sponsor for today's episode, Anthropic, the team behind Claude. Have you ever wished you could hand off a task to someone while you're on the go? Claude is the collaborator that actually understands your entire workflow and things with you.
最终，它被取代了。随着时间的推移，一切都会被取代。真正的悲剧在于我们在过程中失去了什么。让我们休息一下，谈谈我们今天节目的赞助商，Claude背后的团队Anthropic。你是否曾经希望在你忙碌时能把任务交给别人？Claude是一位真正理解你的整个工作流程并与你共同思考的合作伙伴。
Integrate Claude into any part of your project, keeping you focused on solutions. As your research assistant, Claude's research capabilities are comprehensive, reliable analysis with proper citations, turning hours of research, into minutes. Claude becomes your command center by connecting to your professional tools like GitHub, Jira, HubSpot, Notion, and Google workspace. Build interactive tools and apps by describing what you need. Delegate tasks big and small with co-work so you can handle other work while Claude runs.
将Claude集成到你项目的任何部分，让你专注于解决方案。作为你的研究助理，Claude的研究能力是全面的，可靠的分析并带有适当的引用，将数小时的研究变成几分钟。Claude通过连接到你的专业工具（如GitHub、Jira、HubSpot、Notion和Google Workspace）成为你的指挥中心。通过描述你的需求来构建交互式工具和应用程序。通过协作委派大小任务，这样你可以在Claude运行时处理其他工作。
It even has checkpoints that lets you save progress and roll back to any previous state instantly. And when all the work is done, Claude can help you create a polished document, spreadsheet, or presentation directly in your file system. No need to worry about rough drafts that need heavy editing. For problems worth solving, get started with Claude at clod.aI. That's clawed.aI. By 1982, the Bell system was at the peak of its powers, but its monopoly was built on a shaky foundation.
它甚至有检查点，让你保存进度并立即回滚到任何以前的状态。当所有工作完成后，Claude可以帮助你直接在文件系统中创建一个精美的文档、电子表格或演示文稿。无需担心需要大量编辑的草稿。对于值得解决的问题，请访问clod.aI开始使用Claude。即clawed.aI。到1982年，贝尔系统处于其权力的巅峰，但其垄断地位建立在不稳定的基础上。
When Vale makes a deal with the U.S. government in 1915 to like, we'll play nice if you guys let us build this thing out, He sort of gets a promissory note for them that they don't call in for seven decades. Like, the idea to let AT&T do what it wants to build this network out was always a compromise and a compromise that had to come due. The government began to rethink the monopoly they had allowed Bell to run for so many years. Things had changed. The country had been connected. Bell had already done the job.
当维尔在1915年与美国政府达成协议，比如，如果我们让你们建立这个东西，我们会表现得很好，他实际上为他们获得了一张本票，七十年来他们都没有兑现。就像，让AT&T做它想做的事来建立这个网络的想法一直是一种妥协，一种必须到期的妥协。政府开始重新思考他们允许贝尔运行这么多年的垄断。事情已经变了。国家已经连接起来了。贝尔已经完成了这项工作。
AT&T fulfills every ounce of its promise to build a robust network. where people can talk across the country and it feels like they're in the next room. And now that they've built the thing, they just don't need them to be that big anymore. Yeah. The government broke up the bell system into eight different companies. The baby bells, as they were called, controlled different regions of the U.S. New long-distance carriers were allowed to offer service on bell telephone lines, which was great. Long-distance prices came way down.
AT&T履行了其建立强大网络的每一分承诺。人们可以在全国各地交谈，感觉就像在隔壁房间一样。现在他们已经建立了这个东西，他们只是不再需要他们那么大了。是的。政府将贝尔系统拆分为八家不同的公司。所谓的“小贝尔”（Baby Bells）控制了美国的不同地区。新的长途运营商被允许在贝尔电话线上提供服务，这太棒了。长途电话价格大幅下降。
Cheap plastic phones and cordless phones could be purchased at Kmart, none of which had the post-apocalyptic reliability of the 500 series, but you could also buy a phone with a clear case so you can see the wires inside and it lit up when it rang. It was so cool. Meanwhile, and over many more years, analog was being replaced by digital and a new technology was emerging that would make having control over all that copper wire not matter so much. Cellular phones not only are becoming less expensive, they're getting smaller. One piece, handheld, not car phones, street phone. Interstage left, the cell phone. Gone were the days of speaking into membranes and vibrating copper wire across an entire country.
廉价的塑料电话和无绳电话可以在凯马特（Kmart）买到，没有一个具有500系列的后启示录般的可靠性，但你也可以买到一部带有透明外壳的电话，这样你就可以看到里面的电线，而且它响铃时会发光。这太酷了。与此同时，在更多年里，模拟信号正在被数字信号取代，一项新技术正在出现，这将使控制所有那些铜线变得不再那么重要。手机不仅变得越来越便宜，而且越来越小。单件式、手持式，不是车载电话，街头电话。舞台左侧，手机。对着膜片说话和在整个国家振动铜线的日子一去不复返了。
Cell phones were digital, and digital phones had a new way of doing things. In the simplest possible terms, when I speak into a phone, my voice is being broken into discrete sounds of a certain length. And the computer has a library of sounds. that it describes to my voice as a code. So if I go, maybe it's got that sound stated as sound number 41. And then when I finish with a consonant, like that's sound number 43.
手机是数字化的，数字电话有一种新的做事方式。用最简单的话来说，当我对着电话说话时，我的声音被分解成一定长度的离散声音。计算机有一个声音库。它将我的声音描述为代码。所以如果我说“嗯”，也许它把那个声音定为声音编号41。然后当我用辅音结束时，比如“哒”，那是声音编号43。
This is grossly oversimplified. But the computer takes my voice and breaks it down into numbers that equate to the sounds that then get reassembled by those numbers by the other telephone and wrapped into a simulacrum of my voice. for the other person.
这被严重简化了。但计算机获取我的声音并将其分解为等同于声音的数字，然后由另一部电话通过这些数字重新组合，并包装成我声音的模拟物，给对方听。
It is not like a audio signal is being transmitted over the wires. That takes too long. The audio signal is being encoded and then decoded. So the pioneers who made the cell phone had to make a difficult decision. Cell phone companies
这不像音频信号正在通过电线传输。那需要太长时间。音频信号正在被编码，然后解码。所以制造手机的先驱们必须做出一个艰难的决定。手机公司
had a choice to make when they were first transmitting voice. They could prioritize the lack of latency or they could prioritize voice quality. Meaning, should they prioritize how quickly the audio would transmit to another phone, that's the latency, or how clear the audio should sound when it gets there. That's the quality. They made the choice to go for quality.
在首次传输语音时必须做出选择。他们可以选择优先考虑延迟的缺乏，或者优先考虑语音质量。意思是，他们应该优先考虑音频传输到另一部电话的速度（即延迟），还是音频到达时听起来应该有多清晰（即质量）。他们做出了追求质量的选择。
And that was literally a cost-benefit analysis they made about what the public would care more about. The delay in a call using the 500 series, which operated on the copper wire infrastructure, was virtually unnoticeable to the human year. on a coast-to-coast call, the delay would only be around 25 milliseconds. But the digital cell phone is different. It takes between 150 and 250 milliseconds. 250 milliseconds is a quarter of a second. So that's 25 milliseconds for analog compared with 250 milliseconds for cell phones. Remember, the cell phone is converting voice into numbers,
这实际上是他们关于公众会更关心什么的成本效益分析。使用500系列电话（在铜线基础设施上运行）的通话延迟对人耳来说几乎是无法察觉的。在跨国通话中，延迟只有大约25毫秒。但数字手机不同。它需要150到250毫秒。250毫秒是四分之一秒。所以模拟电话是25毫秒，而手机是250毫秒。记住，手机正在将声音转换为数字，
bouncing those numbers off a tower, and then maybe a satellite in space, and then back down to Earth, and then another tower. and converting those numbers back into sound on the receiver's phone. So if anything, it's kind of a miracle that it only takes that long, but the tradeoff is still real. When you look up the specs on phone latency today, they will say 150 milliseconds isn't really noticeable. And I would like to point out, when you're at the end of your day and you call your partner on your phone,
将这些数字从一个塔反弹，然后可能是一个太空卫星，然后回到地球，然后是另一个塔。并将这些数字转换回接收者电话上的声音。所以如果有什么的话，它只花那么长时间简直是个奇迹，但权衡仍然是真实的。当你今天查找电话延迟的规格时，他们会说150毫秒并不是真的那么明显。我想指出的是，当你一天结束时，你在电话里给你的伴侣打电话，
and it's just a check-and-call, how was your day? It was great. What do you want for dinner? I was thinking burgers. Okay, I'll pick those up. That is a really easy call to have because as a couple, you have a rhythm of how to do that kind of check-in. And the back and forth is a known quantity. But try and have an argument on the cell phone where you absolutely cannot interrupt.
这只是一个例行电话，你今天过得怎么样？很好。你想吃什么晚餐？我在想汉堡。好的，我去买那些。这是一个非常容易进行的通话，因为作为一对夫妇，你们有一种进行那种例行检查的节奏。来回往复是一个已知量。但试着在手机上争论，你绝对不能打断。
And 150 milliseconds makes an argument impossible because you are, no, okay, you go, you go, right? You are always wanting to interrupt. The interruption happens much later than you think you can't get a rhythm. and now you're both annoyed that you can't actually communicate across this thing. That 150 millisecond delay to me is deadly in terms of intimacy. And if the cell phone and digital phone calls are to be considered the killer of intimacy over long distances, then there can be only one chief suspect for the crime. The error apparent to the 500 series.
而150毫秒使得争论变得不可能，因为你总是，不，好的，你先说，你先说，对吧？你总是想打断。打断发生的时间比你想象的要晚得多，你无法获得节奏。现在你们俩都很恼火，因为你们无法真正通过这个东西进行交流。对我来说，那150毫秒的延迟在亲密关系方面是致命的。如果手机和数字电话通话被认为是长距离亲密关系的杀手，那么这起犯罪只能有一个主要嫌疑人。500系列的继承者。
In many ways, you could argue that the iPhone has taken the place of what the 500 series was in our lives. While the iPhone is an unbelievable, unmeasurably important invention. The iPhone's amazing. Like, let's just stipulate that the iPhone's amazing. The iPhone is amazing, and I can't stand to have it more than 10 feet for me. That's how amazing it is. When Western Electric made the 500 series, they were manufacturing the perfect telephone that would last for decades in our home.
在许多方面，你可以说iPhone已经取代了500系列在我们生活中的位置。虽然iPhone是一项令人难以置信的、无法估量的重要发明。iPhone太棒了。就像，我们姑且认定iPhone太棒了。iPhone太棒了，我无法忍受它离我超过10英尺。这就是它有多棒。当西部电气制造500系列时，他们正在制造完美的电话，可以在我们家里使用几十年。
The design brief for the iPhone is entirely different. It's really a pocket computer, camera, and media player. The phone part of the iPhone may be its least important part. When Apple markets a new iPhone, they tend to brag about the camera or the storage. They don't really say that the phone is better in this new one. The one thing that we call it is the one thing that it does the poorest of its tasks, which is to be used as a phone. Today, you know, cold calling is an aggressive act.
iPhone的设计理念完全不同。它实际上是一台口袋电脑、照相机和媒体播放器。iPhone的电话功能可能反而是它最不重要的部分。当苹果公司推销新款iPhone时，他们往往会吹嘘摄像头或存储空间。他们并不会真的说这款新手机的通话功能更好。我们称之为“手机”的东西，恰恰是它所有功能中做得最差的一项，那就是作为电话使用。如今，你知道，冷不丁地打个电话是一种侵略性行为。
And I feel like it's an aggressive act because talking to someone, you don't know with 150 to 250 seconds of latency is non-trivial. And we have to navigate more than just the social dynamics of the call. And that means that there's friction between the object and its utility. Eliminating friction between an object and its function was the driving principle behind all of Dreyfus's design. Modern cell phones abandoned this when it came to human conversation. And Adam thinks this abandonment plays a big role in why young people hate being
我觉得这是一种侵略性行为，因为与一个你不认识的人进行有150到250秒延迟的交谈绝非易事。我们不仅要处理通话中的社交动态，还要应对更多问题。这意味着物体与其效用之间存在摩擦。消除物体与其功能之间的摩擦是德雷福斯所有设计背后的驱动原则。现代手机在人类对话方面放弃了这一点。亚当认为这种放弃在很大程度上导致了年轻人讨厌
on the phone. A you-switch survey found nearly 70% of people. Ages 18 to 34 prefer a text to a call. Adam has seen his own kids avoiding phone calls, but he thinks they have been replaced by something else. My kids were in high school, and they would Zoom or FaceTime with their high school girlfriends, and they'd fall asleep next to each other.
打电话。YouGov的一项调查发现，近70%的18至34岁的人更喜欢发短信而不是打电话。亚当看到他自己的孩子也在回避电话，但他认为电话已经被其他东西取代了。我的孩子们上高中时，他们会和高中女朋友通过Zoom或FaceTime视频通话，然后就在彼此的陪伴下睡着了。
And I love this. This was the same thing as sitting there talking on the phone for three or four hours. And he thinks the reason why they're choosing video calls is a question of intimacy. Given high enough speed internet, the latency can be pretty good. But it's the pictures that really help. Having a visual like Zoom, getting social cues by someone's body language, that feels like it supplies some of the intimacy that's lost with the latency.
我喜欢这样。这和坐在那里打三四个小时电话是一回事。他认为他们选择视频通话的原因是亲密感的问题。在网速足够快的情况下，延迟可以控制得很好。但真正有帮助的是画面。拥有像Zoom这样的视觉效果，通过对方的肢体语言获取社交暗示，这似乎弥补了因延迟而失去的一些亲密感。
Adam also points out another fundamental change in our phones that maybe only someone like Adam would articulate, but everyone feels it in some way. The 500 series wants you to take it apart. I think that the phone handset might be the very first machine I ever took apart because you could just unscrew these robust pieces of nylon and you saw this little microphone element and I noticed it was slipping on two commutators and even at like eight years old when I did this,
亚当还指出了我们手机的另一个根本性变化，也许只有像亚当这样的人才会表达出来，但每个人在某种程度上都能感觉到。500系列电话希望你把它拆开。我想电话听筒可能是我拆过的第一台机器，因为你可以直接拧开这些坚固的尼龙部件，看到那个小小的麦克风元件，我注意到它连接在两个换向器上，即使在我八岁的时候，当我这样做时，
I remember thinking, oh, that is a really replaceable part. Like there's some aspect of the reason the phone was built the way it was that I sort of groked. I don't think that's me being brilliant. I think it's about this object being so perfect. It, like, communicates how much energy went into making it so easy to use. The 500 series used interchangeable parts for the better part of a half a century. This is because Bell made the phone to sell to itself and they just rented it to you.
我记得当时想，哦，那是一个非常容易更换的部件。就像手机被设计成这样是有某种原因的，我似乎领悟到了。我不认为这是我有多聪明。我认为这是因为这个物体太完美了。它传达了在使其易于使用方面投入了多少精力。500系列在半个世纪的大部分时间里都使用可互换部件。这是因为贝尔公司制造电话是为了卖给自己，而他们只是把它租给你。
So they built it to last. But we're not renting an iPhone, meaning there's an incentive for it to change and upgrade and not be robust enough to, last for years and years. Every change means we need a whole new phone, which means more money for the people who make them. Even the very design of our phones disincentivizes us from opening them up at all. I'm a big proponent of the right to repair movement, which is really catching fire around the United States. More and more states are passing right to repair legislation, allowing people the right to open up the devices they own. We are actually at a moment culturally where we are redefining what it means to own something. And commerce would prefer a subscription model for everything.
所以他们制造它是为了耐用。但我们租的不是iPhone，这意味着它有动力去改变、升级，而不是足够坚固到可以使用多年。每一次改变都意味着我们需要一部全新的手机，这意味着制造它们的人能赚更多的钱。甚至我们手机的设计本身也让我们根本不想去拆开它们。我是“维修权”运动的坚定支持者，该运动在美国正变得非常火热。越来越多的州正在通过维修权立法，允许人们有权拆开他们拥有的设备。我们在文化上确实处于一个重新定义“拥有某物”意味着什么的时刻。而商业更倾向于为一切事物采用订阅模式。
You know, it's really, there's kind of an irony here how much you felt intimately connected to your household phone. But you owned it less than you own anything else. But for some reason, you felt more connected or felt more like you could take it apart and unscrew the mouthpiece and look at what was inside. Absolutely. Which is why I think Adam Savage can't get over the Western Electric 500. Series. It said, I can communicate across the world and you are talking to a person and it feels just like language the way you know how it works. And it did. It solved that problem. And now we have that problem again of real communication with voice. The 500 series was the ultimate vision of Dreyfus's ideal, the frictionless device that allowed you to talk to anyone in the world. It was a device that met you on your terms, designed to mold to your hand, to be comfortably cradled in your
你知道，这真的很讽刺，你对家里的电话感到如此亲密，但你对它的拥有权却比你拥有的任何其他东西都少。但出于某种原因，你感到更亲密，或者觉得你更可以把它拆开，拧下听筒，看看里面是什么。绝对是这样。这就是为什么我认为亚当·萨维奇对西电500系列念念不忘的原因。它说，我可以与世界各地的人交流，你是在和一个人说话，而且你知道它是如何工作的，这感觉就像语言一样。确实如此。它解决了那个问题。而现在我们又面临着真正的语音交流问题。500系列是德雷福斯理想的终极愿景，即允许你与世界上任何人交谈的无摩擦设备。它是一个按你的方式满足你的设备，设计成贴合你的手掌，舒适地夹在你的
neck, pressed against your ear, hearing someone talk as soon as the words left their lips. It also invited you to open it up and learn how it worked. It's a vision for the objects in our life that seems to have all but disappeared. Well, except one place. The old-timey ring on your iPhone, this is probably the sound of the two-beats. inside the 500 series telephone. Even if it's only in a small way, the memory of the 500 series survives in the very thing that left it behind.
脖子上，紧贴着你的耳朵，在对方话音刚落时就能听到。它还邀请你打开它，了解它是如何工作的。这似乎是我们生活中几乎消失的物体愿景。嗯，除了一个地方。你iPhone上那个老式的铃声，这很可能是500系列电话内部双铃敲击的声音。即使只是以一种微小的方式，500系列的记忆也留存在了那个取代它的东西之中。
Adam Savage, thank you so much for talking with me. I had such a good time. Oh, my God. This was really, really fun, Robin. Adam Savage is a science, technology, and engineering communicator and former MythBuster. If you want to see more of him, check out Adam Savage's Tested on YouTube. If you have a curious mind and love to build things, there's no better place on the internet.
亚当·萨维奇，非常感谢你接受我的采访。我玩得很开心。天哪。这真的非常非常有趣，罗宾。亚当·萨维奇是一位科学、技术和工程传播者，也是前《流言终结者》主持人。如果你想看更多关于他的内容，请在YouTube上查看“Adam Savage's Tested”。如果你有一颗好奇心并热爱建造东西，互联网上没有比这更好的地方了。
A history of the United States and 100 Objects is a production of 99% Invisible and BBC Studios. It's hosted and curated by me, Roman Mars. This episode was produced by Isaac Fisher. Our series producers are Priscilla Alibi, Brenna Daldorf, and Ellie Lightfoot. This series was edited by Annie Brown and Courtney Harrell. Mixing by Iver Manly. Fact-checking by Amy Bracken. Our theme song is by Swan Real.
《美国历史与100件物品》是99% Invisible和BBC Studios联合制作的节目。由我罗曼·马尔斯主持和策划。本集由艾萨克·费舍尔制作。我们的系列制片人是普里西拉·阿里比、布伦娜·达尔多夫和艾莉·莱特福特。本系列由安妮·布朗和考特尼·哈雷尔编辑。混音由艾弗·曼利完成。事实核查由艾米·布拉肯完成。我们的主题曲由Swan Real创作。
From 99% Invisible, our executive producer is Kathy 2. From BBC Studios, our executive producers are Annie Brown and Courtney Harrell. Our production coordinator is Shan Palais, and the production manager is Mabel Finnegan Wright. Artwork by Stefan Lawrence. 99% Invisible is part of the Serious XM podcast family, headquartered in Beautiful, Uptown, Oakland, California. and BBC Studios is headquartered in beautiful,
来自99% Invisible，我们的执行制片人是凯西·2。来自BBC Studios，我们的执行制片人是安妮·布朗和考特尼·哈雷尔。我们的制作协调员是珊·帕莱，制作经理是梅布尔·芬尼根·赖特。艺术设计由斯特凡·劳伦斯完成。99% Invisible是Serious XM播客家族的一部分，总部位于加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰住宅区。而BBC Studios的总部位于美丽的
White City, West London. If you want to get in touch or have an object for us to consider, email us at 100 Objects at 99PI.org. Thank you again to the sponsor of today's episode, Anthropic, the team behind Claude. Claude is the collaborator making your day-to-day life easier. Set up workflows with co-work to run on a schedule like daily reports and weekly summaries.
西伦敦的白城。如果你想联系我们或有物品供我们考虑，请发送电子邮件至100objects@99pi.org。再次感谢今天节目的赞助商Anthropic，Claude背后的团队。Claude是让你的日常生活更轻松的合作伙伴。设置工作流与协作工具按计划运行，例如每日报告和每周摘要。
Claude can scan your Slack and email to build you a prioritized action list. That's how I use it for this project, actually. It takes all the suggestion emails and puts them in the spreadsheet for me so I can check them all out and share them. You can build interactive tools and apps by describing what you need, like custom calculators, data visualization dashboards, even prototypes, all without writing a single line of code.
Claude可以扫描你的Slack和电子邮件，为你建立一个优先级的行动清单。事实上，我就是这样在本项目中使用它的。它把所有的建议邮件都放进电子表格里，这样我就可以查看并分享它们。你可以通过描述你的需求来构建交互式工具和应用程序，例如自定义计算器、数据可视化仪表板，甚至是原型，所有这些都不需要编写一行代码。
For problems worth solving, get started with Claude at clod.aI. That's clod.aI. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
对于值得解决的问题，请访问clod.ai开始使用Claude。网址是clod.ai。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。